Chris Berman the legendary broadcaster
from the mothership helped build the
place and I felt prime time and he's
coming back to the mothership after the
conference championship games and the
Super Bowl this Sunday show will be
special for Chris as he's paired with I
believe Tom Jackson is gonna be back
there with him the original co-host from
NFL primetime and Chris joins us from
Hawaii Aloha Chris how are you today to
use the weather report at 6:30 in the
morning George Carlin once said widely
scattered dark back in the archives just
like we are for primetime how are you
pal good how difficult was it to get
acclimated to watching an NFL game at
7:00 a.m. on Sunday and then the late
game would be at 10:30 it was it wasn't
now I've only been out here a couple of
wee last couple weeks of the regular
season so was with the time change which
were too busy to change clocks here so
it was an 8 a.m. kickoff ok it was
interesting it to your point Dan so
Jacksonville last week led Pittsburgh
what was it 21 nothing I don't think I'd
finished my omelet you know it was it
was pretty interesting it was that's how
they watch football out here and then
they have a nice afternoon
well of course after they watch you on
the Sun of course then maybe they'll
miss the first half of that and come
back later but who would be the
professional team for Hawaii who do the
that's I think in the I think there's a
few in the 80's 90's and then some
holdover San Francisco because of Joe
Montana I think there are some Raiders
around there Seahawks cuz a lot of
people have moved from the Northwest but
the game that's on here every week is
Tennessee because of Mariota they're on
every week so that's kind of become the
home game the home team to answer your
question because because of you know
that they're all so proud of him
and well they should be chris is going
back to do NFL primetime with Tom
Jackson you guys were together almost 30
years on that show weren't you
well Johnny Carson and Ed McMahon Dan
were 31 we almost caught him we didn't I
don't know if this counts as a full
season we'll have to talk to the
arbitration please we we were 29 years
it was great we're but yet as you know
you were there during a lot of it all of
it just about it we're best friends we
complete each other sentences and and no
we haven't well we did one of those
Monday night he came back last year and
was one of my Monday Night legends but
but we talk every week and I'll share
this story we were on the phone I
happened to call him at the end of the
third quarter of the Philly Atlantic
game last week we ended up being on the
phone for the whole fourth quarter we
weren't planning it you know if they
don't get a first down here they still
have time to punt and and deal with
tomato but if they get a first down here
talking about Atlanta on the last Drive
this is the drive they got a score on
they can't screw around and it was
really fun was I go sitting next to him
in the room we didn't plan on it it
wasn't any preparation but it was very
natural so hopefully what you see on
Sunday I mean you know I haven't ridden
a bike for a little bit but I'd like our
chances right don't you sure we'll be
all right yeah I mean it's split ball
it'll be great hopefully we have games
close to what the Vikings game was or
the Eagles game was I mean hopefully we
have games like that on Sunday too
to whoop it up but I'm going to face
this one day soon and that is not having
that everyday vehicle to be able to talk
about you know football like you did it
for so long and you were there at ESPN
for such a long period of time and not
that you're not still involved but when
that daily routine or that weekly
routine is not there how do you fill
that void in well it's a longer answer I
don't think you go in planning anything
as you know because we had a big really
great visit at the Super Bowl last year
on the show yeah this was a mutual thing
so it wasn't like oh you're not doing it
now now what needless to say I've had
something else happened this year that
you know was superseded it so as to
answer your question
you find out how much you can get done
on a Sunday you know I wasn't planning
on going down and getting a corner at
10:30 a.m. and at the in September that
I know that sounds trivial it's
different I missed the action to your
point I missed the interaction
I miss my teammates you know I I did
work with the guys at Randy Charles Matt
you know last year I I miss coming in
and doing this what are we going to talk
about this I missed that I still think
that way but I found that and maybe you
know you heard me say it and I think
you'll find it too you don't need to
know everything that we felt we needed
to know to you to do a daily show for
any sport and me too if I didn't talk to
all 32 teams I certainly was trying to
read up about them each week it's okay I
still talk to a lot not necessarily
first so give me something for the show
just so I'm I can watch and I watched it
as a like I did it 20 let's say you know
like we fell in love a football at some
point in our life and I still enjoy
watching the games am i do i watch nine
at once you know like we did in that war
room Dan at nine at one o'clock no there
were some Sunday's I wasn't even near a
TV I played golf in Ireland one week one
week at a playoff baseball game to do
Houston with Boston was a day game at
Fenway on a Sunday so you're just
getting the final scores while I'm
announcing a game in the sixth inning
and it was ok not like it was who I
don't like it anymore but it was okay it
was take a step back and this is how
America watches it I don't want to say
was it education but it was a
reaffirmation of the type of folks who
were watching shows like NFL primetime
that makes sense to you yes yeah
absolutely Chris will be on NFL
primetime coming up this Sunday as he's
reunited with Tom Jackson what was your
reaction to the the missile false alarm
were you on the island at the time yeah
yeah I didn't
it was interesting as it and that's
gonna be a longer answer and people's
panic was understandable when you say
you get 15 or 20 minutes but really if
you think about it where are you gonna
go most of these homes you know don't
have a basement took me back to when we
were really young in the early sixties
right when we did you know the dry food
in the basement in the bomb yeah well I
mean we laughs but we had them or we
were aware of them certainly in public
building schools you wonder how that
gets 9 things were supposed to happen
before that goes out you know as if it
was someone pushed the wrong button on
an elevator I'm not sure that can happen
and I'm the one person that said who
blame I mean it's just it's interesting
the system that it's that delicate what
it does make you think of ok so if that
was happening what would you do there's
not a lot you can do in 15 minutes we do
have tsunami warnings out here and
that's another story but the sirens
never went off Dan which they're
supposed to if this was completely real
not nobody doubted it obviously but if
you like half of it didn't happen on the
warning system so now you're going is it
real or not but it does make you think
about how delicate things are and I will
say we've been reading about North Korea
to Kim you know you know for five six
years out here not just a couple that
maybe mainland us has been really more
delved into the last couple of years for
obvious reasons but we've been reading
let's just hope that never happens
there's no need to ever send out that
warning for real I mean that's that's a
lot of pee I'm eeen everybody has
different stories they called loved ones
and told them they'll I mean that how do
you handled just 15 minutes you know
it's not like we could get six hours
there may be a tsunami coming you know
get some stuff get away from the
lowlands um
a reminder that you're never totally in
paradise right we we had Rich Eisen on
that there's no smooth segue into this
but he he had one question he wanted to
know what nickname you would have for
Adam Thielen the Vikings wide receiver
said we had a bet on what we thought
would be your musical nickname for Adam
Thielen well I used it last year or two
in the limited you know the Blitz was
not primetime but and he's a bigger
player now that he was a year or two ago
I mean I have one it sound like I've
been sitting here for three months
working on the championship game
nickname let's dispel that rumor you
know maybe a mai tai in you come up with
one glad what do you have cuz I've got
it you made it but I've used it so go
ahead okay now I originally thought that
you did Adam hooked on a feeling that
could be that's a good one now the one
that I like more is Adam you've lost
that lovin feelin could do that you
could do more than a feeling Austin but
yes but for whatever reason the one I've
used and again not a ton and certainly
not this year's when he makes a long
catch under highlights because it's a
little longer oh what a feeling dancing
on the ceiling
Lionel riffled okay I went a different
direction than you would have thought
right yeah I did not think you would go
that genre right well no it for whatever
reason I always liked that song by
Lionel Richie and let's let's call it
let's say it's a 22-yard passed down you
know you can really Oh what I feel in
you can almost sing it dance Adams
dancing on the ceiling you know I mean
you you but all of them are certainly
worthy of b-plus or better grade but if
you had a defensive back who allowed him
to get behind him for a big score than
Adam you've lost that lovin feelin as he
goes in the film well listen if he
catches
ten or twelve maybe I'll use them all I
remember one show I think it was all Bob
Dylan songs well there was a backstory
to that yes it was with John Saunders
who else were you mad at management that
time well the back story I don't know
about any one kid so we have the lake
compounds down the road from ESPN as you
know Dan and they had some concerts bob
was playing on a Sunday night and I
wanted to get that Sunday night hour off
which is you know that was the biggest
show right now and was with John
Saunders I want to say late 80s
delayed John Saunders and well no you
can't I said we'll come on it's Bob
Dylan it's about the unit's Bob Dylan
he's like a mile away so in the first
segment alone I think we had 19 or 20
references I mean and in the t's which
is you remember we voiced why write five
second shots of six things or five
things that happened you know I can't
tell you now thirty years later almost
what I put in but you know how does it
feel
yeah we never I mean we we did you know
somebody was won a golf tournament was a
complete unknown you know somebody if it
was another African baseball like the
ball went off the wall and the fielder
fell down so he had no direction hold
somebody was tangled up in blue I'm sure
yeah yeah was great we got about
twenty-eight only you know Hank it's
great to talk to you hopefully we'll
cross paths again at Pebble Beach and
good luck this Sunday please tell Tom
Jackson we said low and Thank You grace
good luck well dad nice being with the
key Shana be with us do we do it again
after the Super Bowl so
help I don't get thrown from the horse
but it isn't our first rodeo we're
really looking forward to it hope
everybody remembers the good old days of
hanging around watching that show
whatever hour it is right thank you
Chris thank you Chris Berman legendary
broadcaster NFL primetime for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]